une solution de livraison à domicile en
l'absence du client voici la freebox
un frigo stocké à l'extérieur de chez
soi fonctionnant à l'énergie solaire
objectif recevoir ces produits frais
commander sur internet est directement à
son domicile
j'ai commencé les premiers croquis de la
freebox en 2015 et son évolution son
développement les boîtiers électroniques
et l'ensemble de la partie intelligence
artificielle et blocs chaîne d'arriver
progressivement les précommandes sont
déjà disponibles pour une livraison en
juillet 2000 vingt cinq mille fridge box
devraient être produites pour un coût
total de 4 millions d'euros
eric et bill est actuellement en levée
de fonds et cherche de potentiels
partenaires
c'est super activités pourquoi parce que
ça se position sur des secteurs et sur
des domaines qui sont très d'actualité
aujourd'hui à savoir l'économie
circulaire le développement durable
quand je pense que on a besoin de plus
en plus de projets dans ce domaine à des
start up des chercheurs des grands
groupes les acteurs de l'innovation de
paris saclay ont participé à cette
deuxième édition de spring avec une
complémentarité entre les territoires
composant le cluster vous avez saint
quentin qui est le pôle économiques
saclay qui est le pôle plutôt
scientifique et versailles qui est
plutôt le pôle culturel donc ces trois
pôles ces trois agglomérations
travailler ensemble pour préparer la
france de demain dans les secteurs les
plus concurrentiels donc voilà pourquoi
on il aujourd'hui la journée de
découverte des innovations s'est
poursuivie à elancourt sur le site
d'airbus
le thème de la visite la cyber sécurité
présentation des enjeux des menaces et
des outils technologiques comme la sib
orange une plateforme d'entraînement
face à des cyber attaques
elle va venir attaquer le serveur qui
est ici et récupérer tous les
utilisateurs qui sont dans ce serveur
est tenté de casser les mots de passe
qui sont un peu faibles
c'est très intéressant pour nous de
rencontrer des partenaires potentiels
divers aussi bien académique des écoles
d'ingénieurs
des pme des start up et c'est exactement
l'objet de spring qui est en particulier
ici à saint quentin en yvelines et sur
paris saclay où il ya un vrai dynamisme
autour de la cybersécurité et la
digitalisation grâce à la protection de
ses clients et à sa capacité
d'innovation airbus cybersécurité
connaît de bons résultats économiques le
groupe a réalisé une croissance de 30%
de son chiffre d'affaires en 2010 8